à 80 ans le trap saint-quentin football
club prend un nouveau départ et devient
l'étoile sportive de trappes le logo
présent sur les maillots des joueurs va
aussi être modifiés avec ce nouveau
cycle les hommes restent mais le club
prend une autre forme un changement de
logo donc de couleur orient de couleurs
que voyais autour de nous le bleu et
blanc on revient aux couleurs on change
de nom et on revient au premier nom du
club parce que moi j'aime bien le retour
aux sources j'aime bien venir aux
ancêtres j'aime bien revenir à ce qui a
fait le club ce changement de nom
apparaît comme un divorce entre la
communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et le club
dont les subventions auraient diminué
ces dernières années suite à des
descentes en division inférieure de
l'équipe première pour exemple en 2013
le club touchera 6900 euros contre 7600
en 2012 j'abandonne le est-ce qu de
saint quentin en yvelines vous l'aurez
remarqué au passage les abandonner on a
eu moins de subventions pour le coup de
la communauté d'agglomération on a eu
des descentes en et en excellence et en
1re div on nous les a supprimés j'en ai
pas vu la couleur depuis depuis 2008 le
club a largement travaillé sur la
formation et sur les valeurs véhiculées
par l'école de football résultat les
équipes jeunes brille à l'instar des
moins de 15 ans qui lutte pour le titre
en division supérieure régionale en
entraînement donc le travail parce que
travail ce qu'on leur apprend à l'école
on prend votre ça revienne c'est au foot
après c'est tout ce qui est resté
solidarité travail collectif et tout
beau travail on attend le mot travail
travail travail pour arriver un jour un
niveau des valeurs qui ont réuni pas
moins de 600 personnes ce samedi pour
souffler 80 bougies du club